alright here we are back again for
another movie retrospective and I'm
really really excited about this one
because this is a movie that as long as
we've been doing these movie
retrospectives I have had this on the
list and we are finally getting around
to doing it because shudder just added
it a couple weeks ago and I was so
pumped when I saw that they'd added a
good old shutter man it's like cuz they
every now and then like they add new
movies every week or whatever in cuts
man and they always add like one or two
that I'm just like woohoo and it was
like on the list I grew up with this
[ __ ] man this one [ __ ] disturb me it
is a very disturbing the other yeah not
to be confused with the others the one
with said Nicole Kidman they might be
which is also very good but I came out
much later the other yeah this is
actually from 1972 now the interesting
thing about this one is that when it
came out it didn't do like all that
fantastic at the box office it just kind
of had a very quiet kind of like hey
here's the movie and then it's gone
again cuz this is around the same time
that you know Rosemary's Baby came out
the omen came out a few years after this
so there was a lot of like these kind of
70s like slow burn killer kids
psychological thriller type of movies
child killer
movie yeah there's killing people yeah
and it's weird there's a seemingly
supernatural element to it
a bunch of McCobb [ __ ] you know stuff
from the grave and the the kid is kind
of like in a situation you're not sure
whether to sympathize with him or to
demonize him yeah that about which i
think is one of the strengths of the
maze that's one of the strengths of the
movie you don't know if he's a good guy
or a bad guy well and I should say this
too now this movie like I said it didn't
it wasn't super well known at the time
and then I feel like it kind of fell
into a little bit of obscurity in the
late 70s and early 80's it must have the
rights of it must been really cheap
because it was on TV you like all the
time which is when I first saw it I
think I saw it in 79 or 80 or something
like that when it was on TV like over
the weekend and I saw it several
subsequent times over the years and it
always like creeps me out
this
some movie that it has a big twist about
an hour in and it's really hard to talk
about the movie without talking about
the twist yeah so I'm probably gonna
spoil it so if you want to see this
movie because I know this is one that I
mean it came out a long time ago but I
realized maybe a lot of people it's so
only new because it's kind of like an
underrated one so you might want to like
actually go watch the movie before you
hear us talk about it in case we spoil
it for you and I'm not saying it's a you
might be able to see the twist coming
because it's been done in several later
movies you know what I mean you know so
it might be more obvious to audiences
nowadays than it was at the time but you
know just in case this I'm giving you a
spoiler alert right now so if so if you
don't want to know like what the big
twist is in the middle then turn it off
and go watch the movie and think of it
so nobody yell at me but so yes this
this movie was actually based on a novel
by Tom Tryon now he started out as an
actor he was in I he was in a couple of
other movies but I actually knew him
from I married a monster from outer
space he was in like some good movies to
not just like be sci-fi but apparently
he kind of got disillusioned with acting
and he decided he would rather be a
novelist and the other is actually his
first novel that came out in 1971 and it
was a big it was actually a big hit big
bestseller so he actually just became a
novelist from then on I also while I'm
talking about him I also highly highly
recommend his novel harvest home which
is really it's so so good it's like one
of the creepiest most unsettling he's
really good as a writer of like sneaking
up on you I hadn't seen this movie since
I was a kid yeah I had neither I first
saw this when I was visiting my dad
Mississippi I think we were planted on
HBO and they'd have it like on heavy
rotation at night yeah it was on movies
and one of the things I didn't remember
about it I guess maybe because I was in
Mississippi the time back in the early
80s when this is playing my Vale 870 I
think it was early 80s is that this was
a depression-era
motif yeah you know that's when this
story is taking place I didn't notice it
it's said in 1935 again like I see it
now when I was going oh okay
this is the 30s out in the country cuz
it kind of look like yeah because if you
lived in a rural area I never see the
car like that you know yeah it was like
oh yeah and the premise of this one is
out in the country as an extended family
living in a kind of country house and
you know a little small town and there's
these two twin brothers these two twin
brothers one of them is the room is
genius one the other one's kind of like
the nice kid yeah it's like a good evil
twin dichotomy right and they're out
getting in and all these little
adventures and troubles and people are
dying because of it and you're not
really sure what the hell's going on and
then later on you find out that that one
that the twins have a grandma she's a
Russian babushka they call her babushka
she's got a Russian grandmother and
she's got some psychic abilities and she
taught I guess the Contin first she's
either a psychic or witch yeah but I
think psychic is what they're talking
about
she teaches him kind of something like
out of the shining called the shine yeah
I mean remember it from from the movie
she teaches him a skill like that about
he can project his mind into form and
into distant places it's like astral
projection well he can see through the
eyes of a living creature perceive
things through their saluting like
Ravens and birds and you know yeah or
other people yeah and you find out that
well I said is it too early to spoil it
yeah probably
okay go ahead going to well let me kind
of yeah let me kind of like set the
stage so like I said I get put a teaser
out there tease it first man style this
is what it's about okay so yeah as we
said this is actually set in 1935 it's
supposed to be set in small town kind of
like rural Connecticut although they
actually proud they shot it in
California yeah just because of the
seasonal issue that they had they wanted
a shooting
but they couldn't because it was too
cold and they wanted supposed to be the
summertime John Ritter river from
Three's Company who's a kid yeah he had
a very very small role in this I think
this might have been his first film role
which I'm not mistaken it's a very very
small party's probably only in it for
like two or three minutes but yeah the
the stars of the show are the twin boys
who in the movie are named Niles and
Holland Perry they're played by
real-life twin but it's not one kid like
playing two words it's real-life twin
brothers
their names are Chris and Martin advance
how you pronounce it's a Russian name
this as far as I know this is the only
movie they ever did they didn't do any
other movies after the good job yeah
they did and I do not like kid actors
generally but these two were so so good
and so so believable and it's kind of
like interesting that they didn't have
any interest in acting after this I
guess I think Chris became an EMT and he
died pretty young when he was 49 and I
think the other ones still alive as he's
a massage therapist or something like
that yeah but yeah I think this was the
only movie they were ever in now their
grandmother Aida is actually played by
Judah Hagen who is actually a Russian
immigrant now this might be this I don't
think this was the only movie that she
did she did a couple of other ones I
think this was like her major film role
she was primarily known for stage acts
she was Broadway actors very very famous
probably even more famous as an acting
coach you know she wrote several books
on the craft and everything like that so
you know she's much better known for
this but she's also phenomenal this so
that's kind of you know the main you
know triangle of his the is her and the
two boys now like I said yeah there's
there's so much cool about this but it's
this extended family they live in a big
farm now before the movie starts the
boy's father has died in ostensibly
an accident and their mother really
clarified I don't think was it yeah but
I think the implication was that it was
not an accident
he actually died in the I think it's the
Apple cellar which is why the boys
aren't supposed to play in there you
know what I mean they have it all locked
like their uncle's always like getting
up there yes a lot of different angles
in this movie that then don't come on
hitch in the face you gotta you gotta
follow it all the way to pay close
attention yeah what everything is said
the way that the way everything is shot
you have to pay attention to it because
there's a couple things that you the
main characters are these twins and
you're kind of seeing everything from
their point of view so you kind of have
a kids I view this situation didn't it
yeah the adults aren't necessarily
giving you all the information that they
would give it a dud give another an
adult you know talk about yeah so you're
kind of you kind of feel like you're at
the level of these kids and I think that
that's what the director what was
getting at wrong I mean the guy that
directed this Robert Mulligan he's
probably best known for directing To
Kill a Mockingbird he also did summer 42
and some other ones like that but he was
really good at directing this Tom Tryon
who wrote the novel also wrote the
screenplay and I think that he wanted to
direct it and he was kind of annoyed
that he didn't get to so he had kind of
come out later and said that he was very
disappointed in the movie like he didn't
think it was as good as it could have
been and it kind of bummed him out but I
don't know if that's because cuz I think
it's an amazing movie and I think it's a
really good because I've read the book
also I think it would carry at least
yeah I think it's a really good
adaptation and like I said I think it
might have just been a case of him being
bitter that he wasn't allowed to direct
it because they went with the director
that was you know unknown quantity
rather than just a novelist so you know
but one thing another thing I like about
this too is the cinematography and this
is gorgeous it looks like the whole vibe
of this movie gives me like a sort of
Norman Rockwell yeah but like seedy
underbelly of not seedy but just like
darker
yeah like the horror of that's lurking
under Americana you know I mean it has
that very much which harvest home time
try out some other novel has that the
theme is there's a normal appearance to
things but there is not a normal reality
underneath these the appearance of this
yeah yeah I mean there's some bad [ __ ]
happening with these kids and what these
kids are doing is bad even though you
know some of the some of the adults are
kind of knows
was wrong but they're they're hiding it
yeah because there's a lot of [ __ ]
that's not like I said you know before
the movie starts the dad is dead and you
think that oh he just fell in the cellar
and he died and it was a terrible
accident you can kind of feel that
people suspect the kids did it
yeah but then like you know their mom is
um you know she had a nervous breakdown
or whatever she never comes out of her
room you know and she's very she acts
kind of weird toward the kids like she's
very like distant and standoffish toward
them a little bit you know you even
though Niles who was Sid the good twin
he seems very caring and open and
empathetic
whereas Holland is much more mischievous
he's always like pulling cruel pranks on
people yeah you know and things of that
nature so there's that hold I kind of be
going on
so as this story goes on one of the best
things about this like I said and and
Tom trying is good and at doing this in
his novels as well because this novel
and harvest home are really good at kind
of lulling you into this sense of you
know everything's okay it's this bucolic
sort of setting you know what everyone's
nice and down-home and everything like
that but then very slowly he just starts
to ratchet up you know the rot and it's
just really really good how he kind of
does that and I have very rarely read
books like that so very slowly you begin
to see this kind of yeah you know the
these kind of like fraying around the
edges one of the best things I think is
the good twin Niles he has this little
it's like a little cigarette tin or a
little cigar tin or something like that
he carries around in his pocket like
every but like a kid does and see what
does he have treasures in it and it's
got a [ __ ] ring in it yeah it's got a
ring in there which supposedly belonged
to his grandfather yeah and the first
weird thing that happened was that he's
they played with this boy and this boy
saw that ring Higgy yeah yeah I said
he's gonna tell his mom that he had that
ring that he wasn't supposed to have it
that I think he said the old of Dee the
older twin is supposed to have that type
of deal well the older twin was okay the
ring belonged to the grandfather and
the older twin said well it was my ring
of GM and because I got it when
grandfather died so I gave it to Niles
yeah you but then you don't think much
of it at the time maybe later on because
later on it makes a lot more sense what
happened um
Peggy said he was gonna tell their mom
that he had that ring yeah and for kind
of an aunt mysterious he actually at the
time the older brother put a damn
pitchfork and a big old bale of hay
while the piggy was playing and piggy
jumped on the pitchfork and died so and
they set him up to be killed yeah and it
was to hide the secret behind that ring
yeah and you're going like why the hell
why the hell did that happen and then
the movie keeps unfolding and man I
don't know if I I keep wanting to try to
spoil it but well I already told
everybody that we're gonna spoil it what
ends up happening she realized that this
evil twin is a vision he's the actual
twin is dead but the younger brother is
pretending that he's seeing the the
other twin that's why it's called the
other and the weird thing is is that
that ring that ring that they killed
that boy to hide the secret that he had
that ring had been buried with that
brother
yeah but the younger one had it anyway
not only did he had the ring he had the
finger that was one of the bet oh that
was one of the best things that maybe
wasn't but when I saw that in the move
because this is what happens you're
seeing this little tin and it's got the
ring in it it's got some other [ __ ] and
then it's just got this little blue
bundle and you don't know what's in
there and Niles is Niles and Colin's mom
starts to like suspects like what the
hell's going on because not only does
Piggy get killed in a quote-unquote
accident then one of their neighbors
mrs. Rowe she's found dead a couple
weeks after who had kind of [ __ ] with
the kids for like breaking some of their
preserves that they were stealing or
something like that she ends up dead of
a heart attack even though you the
viewer knows that the kids went over
there and scare her and she all these
people start ended up dying across these
boys yeah turns out
and even the mom like falls down the she
doesn't die but she gets paralyzed and
like she can't talk she any parent she
got perished and the mom saw the ring
dead and she opens the body that that
that that that that that the twin had
been did the other twin the dead twin
had been buried with that ring it's a
creepy
well the grandmother finds out about all
this and if it turns out that the
grandmother had taught him the skills
kind of to shining in a way to where he
could believe that the older twin or
that his twin was still alive yeah like
he was seeing through that kids like
this scene or either that or maybe the
dead twin was kind of doing it from
beyond the grave and was like kind of
taken over the good twin there's a weird
yeah there's there's an ambiguity about
how it's one then there's another there
was another another thing that I thought
might have been possible that this good
twin who survived who's imagining that
the bad twin still existing might
haven't actually been the bad twin and
he killed the good twin and that he
assumed his identity yeah that could be
also that the reason why the good twin
was killing people in the name of the
bad twin is because he was the bad twin
all along and it was kind of a weird you
never really know yeah that could be and
like he had taken over the the good one
just to kind of and maybe that's why
everyone was treating him and did they
ever really explain why the other twin
died he fell down the well fell down the
well but wasn't wasn't the other twenty
was ridin round a cat trying to drown a
pair so that's right I think that's what
they said in the movie yeah he was up to
some shenanigans might have been I was
wondering if either he had somehow
psychically resurrected that of the twin
and it was possessing him or maybe
possibility there's a possibility that
he was the bad twin all along and maybe
he had killed the good twin and assumed
the good twins identity it I don't know
it was just kind of something my thought
of at the time yeah I guess I could it
could go either way because it's kind of
inferred that maybe they killed their
dad well for sure I'm responsible about
I think the implication was that they
that the bad twin had killed their dad
because one he fell down the stairs in
the cellar and then later on after their
mom finds the severed finger in the in
the tin she also gets pushed down some
stairs and even though she doesn't die
she's all paralyzed and she can't talk
anymore so she can't you know narc on
him
yeah the bunch of stuff happens in the
family and the extended family and the
boy to cover his own tracks of kind of
the kind of the evil that he's done and
to hide the secrets that he's that he's
holding they decide to set up they kind
of had it I guess you would call like a
feeble-minded Ranch Hand yeah and they
set him up for the labor Victor French
they sent him up for the murder of their
own sister you know my sister had just
been born they were jealous of the
little baby because it was getting the
babies getting all the attentions and
there's this creepy scene where they're
looking all over for the baby and they
finally find it in a bit in a jug of gin
when the gin or wine yeah or something
like there's a wine color they open it
open and that means to the top of that
baby's head float oh that freak
well they don't usually kill baby yeah
baby floatin in the top of its head into
damn gin and then they went out in the
lynched they lynched the ranch hand over
the feeble-minded guy and he was some
kind of Italian or something I think he
didn't yeah I think English too well
yeah it was something like that yeah and
yeah if that was a way of getting rid of
their little sister and then that pushed
some other people over the edge so he
could just be with his mom right his
paralyzed mom yeah well the creepy thing
about this like I said is that um yeah
the baby was actually they they had a
sister named
torie and she was the one who was
married to John Ritter's character who I
think his name was writer yeah and so
she was pregnant through most of the
movie and you think that Niles is all
into it like he's he's psychic so he's
like oh it's gonna be a girl and all
this other stuff now if you notice they
never I don't think they ever make an
explicit reference to this but if you
look in a lot of [ __ ] in the background
of stuff that's hanging on the
kids bedroom walls and stuff he was
super fascinated by the Lindbergh
kidnapping which happened you know a
couple years before that I think or
around the same time and when the baby
disappears because remember they go up
to the UM
they go up to the to the nursery and
that creepy like doll lamp is laying in
the crib instead of the baby yeah that's
what happened and there's a ladder down
the window that's what happened in the
when the lid burn Lindbergh baby I can't
navigate oh so that's what that's a
reference to even though they don't
explicitly make that clear um but I
noticed it this time around like I
noticed all the all the newspaper
articles in the background of the
Lindbergh kidnapping and I think they
even like had a radio thing like on to
the background about it or something so
the kid was like obsessed with that and
so I at some point he goes and takes um
a tree and drowns the baby and a wine
cask and that's to me that scene would
every time I think of that movie and
like I said I haven't seen it for many
years got a million times when I was a
kid and that creeps me the [ __ ] out and
then we watched it a few days ago when
we saw it on shutter and that scene was
like it just impacted me so much like
seeing them pull the top off that cask
and there's like the top of the baby's
head in there and then like the whole
thing about Niles running into the barn
Holland where is the baby
you know like asking the evil twin
that's not there like where the baby was
and also no [ __ ] and it was just so so
creepy another creepy one was where he's
with Babu's his babushkin is my boost
was getting him to protect his
consciousness into that damn crow yeah
and the crows flying he's to come flying
I'm flying and he goes down to say hi to
the ranch and remember the ranch hand
hit I guess Spears him with a Spears the
bird yeah yeah it was a crow wouldn't it
yeah and kills it and all right I assume
it does the way it's edited I always
thought so yeah then he clutches his
chest like he got stabbed like he got
stabbed yeah there was a weird scene is
stuck with me it's just the whole the
whole tone of it is so so creepy a
creepy time and it's just you wouldn't
think it would be because pretty much
the whole thing is set in like the
summer and it's like just bright
son and it's all pretty and it's all
rural it's kind of what makes it weird
yeah it's like it's a really good
example of like sunlit horror which is
what they call it which is really really
hard to do but when it's done well it's
like really effective and the twins are
basically happy even though people are
dying okay
yeah the evil one I supposedly does it
by accident but he I guess you could say
it kind of makes it look like he's doing
it by axis so he definitely I mean like
he pulls a rat out on the whole lady she
dies of a heart attack but he knew that
she had a phobia of the rats I guess you
could say that by accident but he
definitely did kill the piggy yeah I put
in the pitchfork in there yeah you could
you could say well he didn't know it was
gonna kill him but they definitely
drowned their little sister yeah and
they set up the the hand to take the
fall for it they can itched his ass yeah
but it was and then you know it was
weird had a good end ending on it you
know
babushka figured out what the hell was
going on and she she went in there to
[ __ ] die with him to sacrifice
herself and the boy to the flames yeah
because she knew that there was no
saving him and she blamed herself
because she was the one that taught him
how how do you this do that
that psychic thing which they called the
game or the great game but the thing
about it though and they kind of
reference that later on because when he
was earlier on I think before you found
out that the that Holland was dead Niles
was in church and there was like a
stained-glass window of what they called
the angel of a better day and remember
that their grandma ADA told them that
that's who would come to get them when
they died and so there was a thing at
the end where she was gonna like burn
down the barn with her and Niles in it
and she kind of had a nightgown on that
look like an angel thing but the thing
about it though is that you're meant to
imply that he escaped now I have heard
that when this movie was shown on like
network TV that the very end of it had
like a voiceover that implied not that
Niles had died
that he had got caught and that he was
going to prison or going to an asylum or
whatever why they had to do that because
I think they I think they thought that
for network TV that it was too
disturbing that the kid would get away
with it
no that he would get away with it
because in the movie he gets away with
it because you know the grandmother
stuff on fire down the dam but he but he
is so nobody and and she was the only
one that knew and they assumed that the
ranch hand had killed the baby so they
think Bob's your uncle
everything is yeah back to normal so you
know the movie the last you see of it
he's Niles is up in the window and like
they're like hey you want to say how
much or whatever the mom would have
known that she was paralyzed in that's
what I mean so she couldn't say anything
because she was paralyzed and she
couldn't talk anymore so there was
nobody around that knew his secret
anywhere except for her and she couldn't
say anything this is bizarre flee it is
it's super super creepy and like I said
you know it's I love the seventies
probably my favorite era for horror
movies and it's because of this is
because they have this weird tone it's
like this creepy slow burn there's this
real creepy scene where the surviving
twin remembers the day that his other
twin died I remember it was in a dream
or a vision or a flashback but he goes
up to the to the coffin coffin and it's
open and his brothers saying take the
ring go ahead take it yeah yeah I'm
giving it to you
mmm he couldn't get it off and he goes
well you know what to do and then he
they cut it off with a pair of shears
yeah that's how we got the finger and
because he could cut it up it's just
that that's how he got the finger and
it's how he got the ring it was just a
creepy scene where it's one little boy
taught in again in a casket talking to
another little boy that's kid I saw it
freaked me out yeah there's a lot of
little scenes like that and like I said
they were so good at doing that kind of
stuff in the 70s just this really you
know it's not jump out in your face and
scare you it's not it's just this kind
of slow burn it just gets under your
skin and like there's little details
that just kind of stick with you every
kind of head of tone kinda like a cross
between Carrie
the omen I would probably say is like
along that lines but but not really yeah
there's no way to describe it it's it's
kind of in a way more gross than the
omen the little baby in the cast is a
little more yeah it's like they don't
show that it's not gory or anything like
that but the ideas are weird
yeah the implications of it like I think
that you know seeing that that baby's
head sticking out of the job that really
really bought me killing their little
baby sister twins knocking their mother
down the stairs and paralyzing her
setting people up for murder
twins murderer and other little kids it
was it was weird and I think this really
I think this really benefited too not
only because those kids were such great
actors but also that they were real
twins they're real brothers so it wasn't
a case of like one kid having and they
had to use like trick photography like
to get him to play off each other
although if you notice and I did not
notice this the first few times I saw
this as a kid because why would i but
once you know the twist of the movie and
you can watch the movie with that
perspective they never show the two boys
in the same shot yeah it's always like
panning across and they always show
things from Niles's perspective like
he's looking at Holland you never see
Holland looking at him or that you never
see anything wrong it's kind of like the
Ullman Carrie and Huckleberry Finn mixed
together it has kind of yeah that's a
good it has a Huckleberry Finn
yeah it says this very old Americana
imagine Huckleberry Finn was a horror
movie wasn't about evil kids oh now I
kind of want to see the time somebody
needs to do that has anybody done that
done [ __ ] a very finish kill I really
like killer Kid movies I mean it so if
you like killer kid moves like though
I'm in the bad seed
you know Village of the Damned anything
like that um you would probably dig this
I I would think and I want to say too
that I just recently saw I finally got
around to seeing the more recent horror
movie
goodnight mommy and I kind of feel like
that movie borrowed a lot from this one
it had the same trope of the
WinZip spoiler alert that same trip of
the twins you know where as one of them
one of them was dead but she didn't know
the whole time he could you know you
didn't know it till later on so I feel
like that was an omage to this you know
I mean cuz I just saw that the other day
I'm like it was weird because I just
watched that movie out of the I'd been
wanting to see it because it was on a
list of like setup people recommended
and I watched it we had just watched the
other and I said oh I wonder where they
got the idea unless I'm mistaken the
twins mother in this movie is the woman
who played the doctor in the very first
few seasons of Star Trek the next-gen is
not Beverly Crusher it's that it's the
one yeah yeah yeah at the frizzy red
hair Diana Muldaur I think their name is
she's real young in this and real pretty
you would you not I mean wha took me a
minute to recognize her because the
difference in the hair the Star Trek
outfit I don't think was flattering
towards her but when she's just you know
when you see it yes here yeah it's just
it's weird to see and like I said it was
weird to see John Ritter and this even
though he's only in it for yeah he's
like young he's like maybe 20
yeah he's area and even though he's like
supposed to be like the their uncle you
know you can still tell he's gay as hell
I don't guess the guy just that you know
I mean he's it doesn't strike me as a
straight man well that was the whole
that was the whole joke of Three's
Company yes straight but he was
pretending to be a gay but yeah like I
said it's you know it's like yeah we
spoiled the whole the whole movie and we
were just talking about this you know we
we had a little break but uh we were
just talking about this about it's like
I I like to review these movies but in a
way it's also a retrospective in the
sense that I want to like discuss them
right so lobular listen to this have
seen the movie so they want that's what
I mean because I'm kind of the type of
person that I don't I I don't watch
reviews of movies before I see them cuz
it's like I don't like having my opinion
tainted by some other idiots opinion run
so if I liked a movie and I want to hear
somebody else's take on it then I will
go in and in that case I want kind of an
in-depth discussion I don't care if they
spoil it because I've already seen
it so it doesn't matter to me so we
we've done a lot of back and forth about
should we spoil the movie should we not
generally we don't spoil it if it's new
yeah um but I figure if it's old I I
think the best solution she has to go
watch it is yeah well just tell you like
before hey I'm gonna spoil it cuz like I
said the twist of this movie I mean you
really need to approach this movie if
you've never seen it before not knowing
what the twist is because it'll be a lot
more effective alright it's not
effective you know if you say the repeat
views because it is I knew what the
twist was and I hadn't seen in a long
time and I could kind of see it coming
and and I feel like the trope has been
done so many times since then and this
was actually this was the first movie to
do this but it was a very early example
of it I think it had only been done once
or twice before and maybe not even like
back in the 40s or something so I think
at this point it's been done so many
times like this character has been dead
all along or whatever right I hadn't
seen the movie and so long that I wasn't
sure that the movie was gonna be good
and I wasn't even sure if the movie was
an American movie yeah I thought it
might have been an Italian movie no
because I remember to kind of being
dubbed but then when I saw it it runs
did know it was an American movie mm-hmm
and it was asked it was actually better
than I remembered it yeah I was it
really wasn't really like a cheap
b-movie I kind of I don't know I kind of
remember I remembered those scenes that
stuck out it you know that stuck out
over the years and I forgot the rest of
the movie and I assumed it was kind of
like a cheap Italian BB movie yeah but
no no it's not like that at all it's
pretty good it's better it is better
than I remember it easily one of the
best horror films of the 70s and like I
said I feel like it's one that I guess
it's gotten more of a cult following now
but I think it was kind of forgotten for
a long time I mean I only saw it because
it was on cable like all the time in the
late 70s I always remembered those
scenes the crummy tale the baby and baby
had a baby in the finger the finger and
the key that they were talking and
talking into the kit you know between
the caskets and stuff I remember the mom
unwrapping the thing because I didn't
know what that [ __ ] was in the tin
you don't see it for like 3040 minutes
into the movie it's just like a little
package you're like what is that that
he's always taken out of that little tin
and then the mom is poking through his
stuff and like unwraps it it's like a
[ __ ] figure there it's like god I
remembered but it must have been from
another movie where the uncle comes over
and tells the boy remember that you the
world doesn't you don't owe anybody
anything you don't know the government
anything you don't know
they must've been from another movie
from around that same time yeah maybe I
seen wasn't in there yeah I don't know
what that would have been from yeah it
was something else like that
yeah cuz I don't think that it was I
mean it very well could have been I
think that but in an Italian movie but I
don't think I mean it meshed him in it
doesn't seem to go along with the story
so I'm guessing it wasn't cuz I mean we
did just watch this recently but it was
a few days ago so I don't remember every
single dialogue but yeah so you know if
you haven't seen it like I said we just
boiled it sorry but if you have seen it
you saw it a long time ago give it a
watch again because it really does hold
up like I said one of my favorite horror
movies of the 70s has a really great
creepy vibe to it I just love these
[ __ ] creepy unsettling movies like
this and yeah and like nobody did it
better than they did in the [ __ ] 70s
sure so go check it out if you haven't
already and that will do it for our
movie retrospective of the other from
1972
remember if you liked the show like
share subscribe on all your social media
if you would like to financially support
you can go to our patreon page
patreon.com/lenguin
and there is a little button in the
sidebar to a PayPal account if you'd
like to give a one-time donation
remember these movie retrospectives
which are usually older movies we put
them up every Friday and also we have 13
o'clock matinee three new movies in the
theater that comes out every Sunday and
our regular episodes come out every
Tuesday and if you're a patron you get
early access you get to see all the
stuff a day before it goes live so go
check that out and we will see you next
time bye